so I think for a long time you have to
remember women have been silenced you
know I mean so you've been talking about
women who are being courted and all that
kind of stuff you have to remember
marriages were arranged as well so a lot
of people weren't even marrying for love
so a lot of women were probably in
relationships that they weren't happy
and weren't sexually satisfied because
men let's be honest we know that men for
a long time weren't going down on women
things like that did you go what I'm
saying can I ask you something yeah if
you've had if you've had one partner how
would you know what bad sex is
wait wait I'm just making the same thing
wait where did that come from what did
that have to do with anything because
she said no because the logic behind it
is because if you've never really thrown
your boss it's not that question I'm not
gonna lie it's triggered me already I
know I can see you in your eyes I can
see in your eyes because I'm like why is
the question how will you know if it's
bad sex why doesn't the man want to give
her the best sex no no that's that's not
that's not even that's not what it is
it's not that always saying man or
whatever we A man gives you take it but
it's a fact of like if you haven't
thrown your box around yeah you don't
know you don't know the full range of
the spectrum you know what I'm saying
because if you just go with one guy you
only know that guy and more than often
you will be satisfied because that's all
you know
how would you how would you know how
would you know what a nine inch feels
like if you've never had a nine inch
that's not even a thing
to a degree yes you don't know what
you're missing if you don't have it I
hear it but at the same time
okay so for example I'm African I'm from
the African Community so am I I know
that I know a lot of African women that
were not happy in their marriages but
stayed because it's what you do because
the duty exactly but now I just feel
like women have more of a voice so how
they're using it might be a little bit
rough around the edges and women and
women have more of a voice and more
women are single and we've got more baby
mamas and more women are actually
unhappy
but at the same time are men
amen amen bringing the standards so I'll
ask people myself
hold on hold on
hold on I've been a traditional woman
guys are you a virgin I grew up in the
church
no answer the question oh is it you
asking me wait no no no no no sorry my
husband I I he was the first man I ever
kissed slept with everything so you want
to talk about tradition I was her but if
you're traditional you still have a
husband
so you stay with a man if you if he's
not treating you well we don't know
what's happened so far you're just
assuming you're just assuming okay
just one voice one voice my situation
ended very badly okay yeah that's just
but that's my situation and I'm not
gonna even say too much but as in
abusive all of that yeah yeah I gave him
all that innocence virgin I'm here to
serve you I'm here to be submissive I
was that woman I grew up in the church
everything long skirts all of that and
what I got back was horrible you
understand so now that I'm out of that
situation I'm still traditional on the
inside but I'm not gonna lie I like to
be a bit of a bad bee Okay cool so so
what I'll say in regards to that is I'm
really sorry about hearing about your
situation when it comes down to anything
to do with essay or anything like that
or your obesity anything like that we
just yeah we just support you and just
say yes yeah yeah we just support you
for that in it so just sorry about that
um but then coming outside now it's like
you seem happy to be out in the streets
like it like yeah because the way you're
like yeah and I'm outside I'm a bad beer
I don't know what you think no I said
I'm traditional as a woman like how if a
man comes my way okay the way I see it
is not 50 50. yeah I feel more 70 30.
but the the other 20 that isn't in that
50 we're saving it kind of thing so it's
almost like the man puts him more but
part of my wages will be to save for a
rainy day so it wouldn't just be I'm
using it to get my nails done and all
that I'm quite responsible as a woman
I'm not out here to just spend your
money take me on the holidays and you
pay to be honest I feel uncomfortable
after a while I'd be like babe let me
let me at least give something I'll ask
you a question before we move on to the
next guest show yeah all right so how
did you get with your ex-husband or man
I grew up in the church so it was
through like the church and it was kind
of like an arranged like oh this no no
it was love did you pick him yeah what
was the power meters that made you
choose that guy what was it that
attracted you to that guy
looking back I don't know I I got a good
idea though but honestly that guy did
not have money we were young at the time
so it wasn't you need to have six
figures like it wasn't even like that
what did he look like
you
see
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait
he was he was he was a black man in it
tool handsome five four eleven five foot
eleven handsome what I thought was
handsome at the time
oh well not my type now what's your type
now
the same type but not him basically yeah
you need to be six foot three like no
just don't worry about preferably over
six foot right no I'm like I I saw
someone who was five foot nine and I had
no problem to be honest I'm five foot
six okay and I'll be honest with you I
kind of like how gonna got us a bit
shorter because your tool saw is not at
my head you know what I mean so for me I
don't need the most tall guy but I do
desire to be treated like a princess to
a degree I don't want struggle love do
you get what I'm saying I do like the
idea of it but know that what you're
gonna get back is the woman that wants
to please you wants to make sure you're
looked after but I like to be a bad beat
do you want to be a princess or do you
want to be treated equally
foreign I guess we would need to figure
out what the difference is between the
two thus being treated equally mean I'm
not a princess
you tell me
that is an interesting question I don't
have a very good question actually
because if you're if he's treating you
like a princess and you're just there
you don't have no responsibility
Bros because when you talk about
Princess what's the connotations that
come along with that princess just
sitting in the tower not doing nothing
Ralph doing online
let me let me explain it to you bro when
you say princess yeah it makes that
connotation of you're sitting in the
tower just painting your fingernails
playing in your hair yeah the guy comes
he patterns everything where you live
where you sleep where you eat everything
you don't have to worry about nothing
but the thing about that is without a
responsibility you you don't have no
power do you get what I'm saying so what
he's saying is would you rather be the
princess or be equal with the guy so now
you have a say oh you get what I'm
saying because at the end of the day if
me and you was together and I pay for
everything and you'd have to worry about
nothing I'm in charge bro why I say goes
you're living a good life you can be
living a great life ain't got no worries
all of that bro you're singing bruh yeah
I'm in charge bro if I say uh you're
like oh shall I go to this party I'm
like nah I don't think you should go
then you're not going bro you know what
I think I think this is which one would
you pick I think that this is a hard
question let me get there now I think
this is a hard question to answer
because I feel like in general in life
there should be dynamic range I think
there should be times when my Guy treats
me like a princess let's just say you
book me a holiday for my birthday but
then when we come home and Something's
Happened
you didn't say that at the beginning you
said I think I should be treated like a
princess you didn't know I desire
Dynamics no no okay because I'm I'm
changing it based on the question that
I've been asked but now I've always said
I'm quite traditional I will give it I
will please a man wherever I can I like
the idea of my man coming back and he's
happy to come back I don't like the idea
of my mind being like gotta go back to
her do you know what I mean I want to
make you happy
traditional so you don't mind the man
being the authority over you no I I
don't want like I've I was a youth
pastor in it back in the day so I've
tasted a bit of leadership I'm also a
teacher so I've tasted leadership and
it's not easy I don't envy people in
leadership positions because you know
what the box stops with you if the ship
sinks it's on your head captain you need
to go down with that ship so for me I'm
happy to support I'm actually happy to
support but I feel like this there could
be range there could be times when you
treat me like a princess and the
Samsung's like babe something has
happened we need to sit down and we need
to discuss this what do you think what's
your opinions what what direction do you
think we should go and then even me as a
woman I can sit and be like you know
what babe you could take the lead on
this I'm quite happy because I don't
know it might be something he's stronger
in like Finance for example if I'm
paying for everything I'm taking the
lead regardless bro that's your mindset
but guys
are willing to pay 100 and still treat
their women as equal that's what I'm
saying that's your personal opinion and
that's fair say that again say that
again no he said that if I'm paying 100
know that I heard that part department
I'm saying that there are there are some
men out there that maybe you guys don't
know but there are some men out there
that will do 100 of the payments and
everything yeah and they still treat
their women as eating what do you call
them in men what do you mean Sims
that's not a thing
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible